[Applause]
thank you very much president Ruto
excellencies uh distinguished guest good
good morning what a pleasure to be here
with you indeed it is for me a very
special moment too to be here and it's a
pleasure to be back in
Nairobi and I want to express how much
the European Union values this
partnership with Kenya it is very
important for us we may be on different
continents
but we are so close at
heart we both Champion democracy and
human
rights we both are strong Advocates of
an international rules-based
order and in this regard I thank you for
supporting Ukraine our neighbor and
aspiring
member and I want you to know that the
European Union welcomes and supports
your constructive role role for peace
and stability in the east African region
and in the Horn of
Africa partnership like ours are
precious and because they are so
precious in the times we live in they
need to be
strengthened and that's what we are
doing here today very
concretely with a signature of the EU
Kenya economic partnership
agreement indeed we already have a
thriving trade
relationship the European Union is
Kenya's first export destination and
second largest trading
partner and as it has been said our
bilateral trade amounted to more than3
billion euros last
year but now this agreement will fully
open the European market for Kenya's
products as as soon as it enters into
Force so the do is open tariff free
quota free this will boost your exports
tremendously it will give an incentive
to scale up to create good jobs
here and at the same time and this was
very important for us our agreement is
fair and it is
sustainable because it takes into
account
your need to open your Market only
gradually so there is a long
transformation
period important is for you that certain
products come to the Kenyan market like
the Imports of Machinery from the
European Union um that are crucial here
to
produce but the economic partnership
agreement includes very special
safeguards for agriculture culture and
food security so important as far as
that we bring products to the Kenyan
Market that are necessary here to
produce but that we do not compet
compete with local products so that this
is a fair agreement and a sustainable
agreement this agreement also represents
countless new opportunities for Kenya's
businesses as I said to scale up and to
create good jobs and for us it is a
precious contribution to our
diversification strategy for the
European Union it is very important to
strengthen our supply chains and
diversify them with trusted like-minded
partners and Kenya is a trusted
like-minded
[Applause]
partner so we are deepening trade ties
and we are building up our own economic
result resilience so this economic
partnership agreement is a win-win
situation on both
sides very important for us is also that
whatever cooperation and trade we have
together that as you've said there's
added value and creation of jobs locally
this is very important that the raw
product is not extracted and taken
outside the country
but that the added value is created here
that the supply chain is built here to
create good jobs locally I think this is
a new approach but a very important
one then as you said president Ruto the
agreement is open to the other states of
the eastern African Community and this
makes Kenya a trend Setter a Pioneer
you're showing how to move forward we we
encourage the other eastern African
countries to join this economic
partnership agreement they can only
benefit from the regional integration
and of course it is here in the region
important also amongst yourselves to
open the markets and
finally this agreement also mirrors our
shared values it includes provisions on
labor rights and on gender equality and
the most ambitious provisions on climate
and environment that we have ever had in
a trade agreement with an African
country why was this possible it is
possible because Kenya is a champion
what protection of climate and
environment is
concerned and this is a domain where
Kenya leads by
example I was here in September for the
Africa climate Summit
and you really made Africa's voice heard
and you set the tone I will never forget
how strongly you advocated that you are
part of the
solution it perfectly paved the way for
successful cop
28 and this is also your success dear
president I want to thank you for that
for your determination and your strong
stance on that
one we all know that climate change
impacts Africa more than any other
continent and you know this all too well
you have recently been hit by heavy
floods with devastating
effects we stood right by your side
Kenya has long
understood that the green transition is
the way to mitigate the destructive
impact of climate
change and at the same time to deeply
transform your economy
you called it Go
Green you have launched your green
industrialization efforts we gladly
support them via our global gateway
strategy global gateway is the European
investment program
abroad and with global gateway we invest
almost 3.5 billion euros for Kenya's
green
transition
there are over 150 green Global greatway
projects here in Kenya in the making
clean Mobility is one example with a
Nairobi clean bus Rapid Transit line
three obviously well
known we discussed this in March during
your visit in Brussels right and I
always also want to mention which is
very dear to my heart the green
hydrogene St strategy and road map for
Kenya this is something very special we
signed it together in
September green hydrogene
is the front runner of energy production
for the future the whole world is asking
for it and therefore this road map is
helping you towards your goal to become
a clean hydrogen Hub a front runner with
the European Union's financial support
so overall you are on your best way to
become a renewable Powerhouse reaching
your ambitious Target of 100% clean
energy by 2030 but if I hear that you
are already at 91% now I have not the
slightest doubt that you will reach your
ambitious
goal most importantly it will create
good jobs in the energy sector for your
people especially for the vibrant Youth
and and it of course will give people
access to energy this is one of the main
jobs that we have to
deliver and on this basis we want to go
a step further so we invite you to start
working with us on a green partnership
between the European Union and Kenya
there's so much to identify and good
policy experiences and best practices to
share and to make the green transition a
success at the scale of our
continents to
conclude I want to thank you personally
again dear president for hosting me here
in Nairobi with our economic partnership
agreement we are opening a new chapter
in our very strong
relationship now our effort should be
focused on implementation we have to
deliver for the people and I'm looking
forward to working with you very closely
on that many
thanks my dear friend